do you think ever that Mother Nature has
a plan a bigger plan where in the end it
all ends up that we're like trans like
Ben Simmons is like all like crossed you
know
Ben Simmons is like a um
Mick he's a black and I think he's black
and white right he played at LSU he's a
great basketball player
but he's bait you know what I'm saying
he's beige does it you know what I'm
saying does it end because here we go
what the [ __ ] he's probably like what
the [ __ ] man I'm a man leave me alone
[ __ ] but if he put a wig on no if he
put a wig on and shaved I'm just those
[ __ ] arms and hands yeah you get
tricked by that guy and you want to yeah
you want to get tricked you're trying to
get tricked you like trick me
trick me Ben Simmons
that's a [ __ ] manly man
in hands go
if you think that's a woman I mean maybe
he is now I don't know I don't want to I
don't know anybody's feelings no no it's
six eleven
he's giant go Tigers man he goes LSU
Tiger but what I'm saying is what are
you saying here's what I'm saying man I
can't believe you guys can't understand
me I do understand what you're saying
I'm just [ __ ] around okay okay and
I'm just [ __ ] around too okay
I'm just saying if we're sending
somebody in if they say if the trans
Community is gonna send somebody in a
[ __ ] vouch for them they need to send
in a [ __ ] Warrior you know they can't
send it I don't know what you're saying
okay I thought I knew what you were
saying I switched to a new idea okay
what I was saying is do you think we all
end the same skin color and in some sort
of a trans
sexual type of situation I think it's
very possible that we all become
genderless yes I do think that's
possible
yeah I think that might be what is
happening with like
microplastics or changing people's
hormone systems I don't know if you know
about all that do you know about all
that you know I don't know about it I
mean I appreciate it there's a book
called countdown that's nice of you by a
woman her name is Dr Shanna Swann and
she came on the podcast and she
explained that there's certain chemicals
that are in Plastics and and some
fertilizers that are disrupting the
human body endocrine system and uh it's
causing people's penises to shrink balls
to shrink sperm counts are lowering and
one of the ways they find out about this
is the size of people's taints oh wow
yes and male mammals the taint is 50 to
100 larger than female mammals so like
when they pick up a gerbil that's how
they can quickly tell whether or not
it's a boy or girl is by the size of the
taint and when the introduction of
phthalates it starts with a p p t h a l
a t EES I think it's how you spell it
you say phthalates and phthalates are a
type of chemical that disrupts the human
body and because of the uh use of
petrochemical products the increase of
phthalates into the human body from
contamination has caused people's taints
to shrink balls to shrink dicks to
shrink sperm counts to drop and
miscarriages to go up and they think
that
if you think about that like that is
like causing gender to just kind of
compress and to become like more
ambiguous and in the future if that
continues to happen what what does that
mean like what do we become genderless
and then what do we do to try to keep
the human race alive well we may we may
revert to genetic engineering like some
sort of a genetic like some sort of a
you know medical technological
intervention so we breed from like
splicing jeans so we get enough males
and we get enough females yeah and that
has always been what's crazy about this
is although this sounds nuts we're
talking about it now
for decades people that have been
abducted by aliens have always said that
aliens are performing experiments and
making hybrids with human beings because
their genetic material has run stale
because they're they're they're breeding
or they're rather reproducing through
genetic manipulation rather than through
sex because they don't have sexual
intercourse anymore so they can eat our
eggs and sperm they need all that stuff
they need our material but that because
they don't have that anymore so that
might be where all biological creatures
that develop technology and technology
in our case involves a lot of plastic
the more technology the more plastic the
more plastic in the bodies the more the
bodies become genderless
wow wild and is it and it is if the
sensor is plastic in our water like
little molecules and stuff does that
affect us too do you think yes it
definitely does yeah we uh we found a
statistic that's a little misleading but
the statistic is every week the average
person consumes a credit card sized
piece of plastic
through microplastics Jesus yeah that's
a lot but then Jamie found out that the
way they calculate that is like worst
case scenario like some dude who really
likes you know who sucks on the bottle a
lot of like bottle licking yeah yeah
yeah a lot of them like chewing on
vibrators or chewing on yeah two like
that dog we saw the other day
[Laughter]
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one